Comment peut-on le mesurer ?
Comment l'avons-nous mesuré ?
Il y a environ 50 ans,
des physiciens visionnaires à Caltech et au MIT,
Kip Thorne, Ron Drever, Rai Weiss,
croyaient qu'on pouvait mesurer les distances avec précision
en utilisant des lasers qui auraient mesuré la distance entre des miroirs
éloignés de plusieurs kilomètres.
Ça a demandé beaucoup d'années, beaucoup de travail, et beaucoup de scientifiques
pour développer la technologie, pour développer les idées,
et 20 ans plus tard,
il y a environ 30 ans, plus de 20,
ils ont commencé à construire deux détecteurs d'ondes gravitationnelles,
deux interféromètres,
aux États-Unis,
chacun d'une longueur de 4 km.
Un d'eux se trouve en Louisiane,
à Livingston, au cœur d'une jolie forêt ;
l'autre se trouve à Hanford,
dans l'État de Washington, au cœur du désert.
Dans ces interféromètres, il y a des lasers qui voyagent à partir du centre,
4 km dans le vide,
se reflètent dans les miroirs et retournent au centre,
et nous mesurons la différence des distances
entre un bras et l'autre bras.
Et ces détecteurs sont vraiment très sensibles,
ce sont les instruments les plus précis du monde.
Pourquoi on en a fait deux ?
A cause des signaux que nous voulons mesurer qui viennent de l'espace
- c'est ceux que nous voulons mesurer -
mais les miroirs se déplacent tout le temps,
donc il faut distinguer les effets des ondes gravitationnelles,
qui sont des effets astrophysiques et doivent apparaître dans les 2 détecteurs,
des effets locaux,
qui se manifestent distinctement, dans l'un ou dans l'autre.
En septembre 2015,
nous terminions l'installation de la deuxième génération de technologie
dans ces détecteurs,
mais nous n'avions pas encore atteint la sensibilité optimale souhaitée.
Elle n'est toujours pas atteinte
même si c'était deux années plus tard,
mais nous voulions déjà recueillir des données.
Nous pensions ne pas voir grand-chose,
mais nous nous préparions à collecter des données pendant quelques mois.
Et la nature nous a surpris.
Le 14 septembre 2015,
nous avons vu une onde gravitationnelle
dans les deux détecteurs.
Il y avait un signal
avec des cycles qui augmentaient en amplitude et en fréquence
puis diminuaient de nouveau
et c'était identique pour les deux détecteurs.
Il s'agissait d'ondes gravitationnelles.
Et ce n'est pas tout : en décodant ce type d'ondes,
nous avons pu déduire qu'elles venaient de trous noirs
qui ont fusionné en un seul
il y a plus d'un milliard d'années.
Et c'était...
(Applaudissements)
C'était fantastique.
Au début, nous n'arrivions pas à y croire.
On avait cru que ça n'arriverait pas
avant longtemps.
C'était une surprise pour tout le monde.
Il nous a fallu des mois pour être sûrs que c'était vrai,
parce que nous ne voulions pas laisser de place à l'erreur.
Mais c'était vrai.
Et pour dissiper tout doute
sur la capacité des détecteurs à mesurer ces ondes,
en décembre de la même année, nous avons mesuré une autre onde
plus petite que la première.
La première onde gravitationnelle avait produit une différence de distance
de 4 millièmes de proton
sur 4 km.
Oui, la deuxième détection était plus petite
mais encore très convaincante selon nos critères.
Même s'il s'agit d'ondes d'espace-temps,
et non d'ondes sonores,
nous aimons bien les écouter sur haut-parleurs.
Nous appelons ça « la musique de l’univers ».
Je vais vous faire écouter les deux premières notes
de cette musique.
(Sifflement)
La deuxième note, la plus courte, est la dernière fraction de seconde
de ces deux trous noirs,
qui, pendant cette fraction de seconde, ont émis énormément d'énergie,
autant d'énergie que celle de trois soleils qui se transforment en énergie
selon cette célèbre formule :
E = mc².
Vous vous en souvenez ?
Elle nous enchante tellement cette musique
que nous dansons dessus,
tellement que je vais vous la faire écouter à nouveau.
(Sifflement)
C'est la musique de l'univers !
(Applaudissements)
Souvent les gens me demandent :
« À quoi servent les ondes gravitationnelles ?
Et maintenant qu'elles ont été découvertes,
qu'est-ce qu'il reste à faire ? »
À quoi servent les ondes gravitationnelles ?
Quand on posa la question à J.L. Borges,
« À quoi sert la poésie ? »,
il a demandé en retour :
« À quoi sert le lever du jour ?
À quoi servent les caresses ?
À quoi sert l'odeur du café ? »
Et il a répondu :
« La poésie sert au plaisir, à l'émotion, à vivre. »
Et comprendre l'univers,
cette curiosité humaine de savoir comment ça fonctionne,
c'est un peu la même chose.
Depuis un temps immémorial, l'humanité,
et nous tous, vous tous quand vous étiez enfants,
quand on regarde le ciel pour la première fois
et qu'on voit des étoiles, on se demande :
« Qu'est-ce qu'une étoile ? »
Cette curiosité est propre aux êtres humains.
Et c'est ce que nous faisons en science.
Nous aimons bien dire
que les ondes gravitationnelles sont déjà utiles
parce que nous ouvrons une nouvelle voie pour explorer l'univers.
Jusqu'à maintenant, nous avions vu la lumière des étoiles
à travers les ondes électromagnétiques.
Maintenant, nous pouvons écouter le son de l'univers produit
par quelque chose qui n'émet pas de lumière, les ondes gravitationnelles.
(Applaudissements)
(Anglais) Merci.
Mais est-ce qu'elles ne serviront qu'à ça ?
On ne tire aucune technologie des ondes gravitationnelles ?
C'est possible, oui.
Mais cela prendra probablement beaucoup de temps.
Nous avons créé la technologie pour les détecter,
mais pour les ondes, peut-être que d'ici 100 ans,
on leur découvrira une utilité.
Il faut bien du temps pour tirer une technologie à partir de la science
et ce n'est pas notre but.
Toute technologie est tirée de la science,
mais on fait de la science
pour le plaisir.
Qu'est-ce qu'il nous reste encore à faire ?
Beaucoup.
Énormément. On ne fait que commencer.
À mesure qu'augmente la sensibilité des détecteurs,
- et il reste pas mal de choses à faire -
nous allons repérer plus de trous noirs,
mais aussi nous allons pouvoir les cataloguer, combien il y en a,
où ils sont, leurs dimensions,
et on verra également d'autres objets.
La fusion des étoiles de neutrons,
qui se transforment en trous noirs.
On verra naître un trou noir.
On pourra voir les étoiles en rotation dans notre galaxie
qui produisent des ondes sinusoïdales.
On pourra voir des explosions de supernovae dans notre galaxie.
C'est tout un spectre de sources nouvelles qu'on pourra voir.
Nous aimons bien dire
que nous avons ajouté un nouveau sens au corps humain :
maintenant, au-delà de la vue,
nous avons l'ouïe.
C'est une révolution dans le domaine de l'astronomie,
comme quand Galilée a inventé le télescope,
ou comme quand le son s'est ajouté au cinéma muet.
Ce n'est que le début.
Nous aimons croire
que le chemin de la science est très long -
très amusant, mais très long -
et notre grande communauté internationale de scientifiques qui travaillent ensemble,
dans plusieurs pays, en équipe,
aide à tracer ce chemin,
en faisant de la lumière,
en trouvant parfois des détours,
et en construisant, peut-être,
une autoroute de l'univers.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)